the principal tre livid character unit
principal de feu - John Porter
[Musique]
J'ai toujours rêvé d'être tu sais
peut-être un jour une star du tennis une
belle carrière tu sais que ce serait
fantastique
[Musique]
les routines de beauté se concentrent sur l'Asie  pour
sécuriser quand c'est habituellement le possesseur de la vision
Nokomis une détection moindre Daniel
festival peeler
[Musique]
un policier cusimano Le mari de Dana
Martin Angus Kagan de l'excès hors du
patio rôti Conda mon respect
ouais précision allez merde
[Musique]
les cours Beautyrest font anima Mundi
et  secret
[Musique]
Je n'ai jamais pensé que je jouerais au
tennis en ayant des enfants, ce n'était pas dans ma
vision de rêve quand j'étais petit garçon, ma
vision en tant que petit garçon était peut-être de
conserver mon titre à Wimbledon et de voir mes
parents là-bas, puis tous  tout à coup,
vous avez une femme merveilleuse et quatre
enfants qui vous regardent,
vos parents et vos amis et c'est
devenu bien plus qu'un simple c'est mes
rêves et ça ne m'a pas emporté aussi loin
[Musique]
si vous disiez au  les gens que je viens
jouer à Wimbledon pendant les 20 prochaines années,
je vais en gagner huit, ils vont dire
ouais tout ce que vous savez comme un
petit enfant suisse comme s'il avait perdu la tête,
vous savez que
ma mère est d'Afrique du Sud
évidemment  il y a aussi des
zones plutôt difficiles que vous connaissez en
Afrique du Sud et elle a toujours dit que si jamais j'avais
l'occasion de redonner, vous
savez que je devrais certainement le faire et je n'ai
plus vraiment hâte de
dépenser et de donner plus de temps et d'argent dans
le  l'avenir et c'est définitivement
quelque chose que je veux que vous sachiez porter
au-delà de vous connaissez mes jours de jeu et
faire autant que possible
même si c'est une grande
partie de ma vie, mais j'essaie vraiment
de faire quelque chose de plus décalé maintenant
[Musique]
Roger Roth est probablement les deux plus grands
joueurs qui aient jamais joué au jeu pour lequel ils ont tant fait
pour le tennis en général
[  Musique]
[Musique]
Je n'ai jamais pensé que ça allait se reproduire
tu sais j'ai mes moments
je veux dire j'ai travaillé dur j'ai eu de la chance je
suppose
[Musique] [
Musique]
toi